well back in 1939 you publish the story
the dopes were the first flight around
the moon and back Frank Borman and his
Apollo 8 crew actually carried this
mission out in 1968 you placed the story
in 1974 how does a science fiction
writer feel when something like that
happens well it makes him feel very good
I'm a little annoyed with myself because
I was so conservative
you see I'm six years behind and also I
didn't allow for the various things we
did before then men and flight men
docking mid-course corrections I just
had someone get into a ship and go
around one man and that makes me feel as
though I wish I could do it more often
but as a matter of fact we go through
all my books you'll find that the number
of things I've spoken about that have
really come true are very small that
probably goes for other science fiction
writers as well oh yes when people talk
about how science fiction writers
predict the present it's because they've
gone through a large corpus of work and
picked out certain things we can't just
predict there isn't enough story
material and straight prediction we make
up futures it doesn't matter whether we
really think they'll come to pass or not
but we ask ourselves only will this be
interesting to deal with well let's make
a nice story and then if some of them do
come true
well good
you